[Music]
i'm donna i'm from providence donna yes
and i'm really pleased to meet all of
you namaste
i've taken yoga for many years part of
my simplifying and improving my life um
beautiful so
my journey began
30 plus years ago when i at that time
was in my 20s and bought a 14-room house
that needed a lot of work so lots of
changes in my life went through
and i now live in a studio apartment and
i don't even have a separate bedroom um
which is a little small for me but it's
it's fine it's been almost four years i
am trying to get something bigger but
um
so
i i also improved within five years of
starting my own business as a house
cleaner something i should have done a
long time ago i am a creative person by
heart and i didn't realize how much i
hated desk jobs and
just confined spaces and dealing with
the regular public and all of that how
much i hated it so
it came to kind of a dead end and then i
just said what can i do and i just
started
house cleaning and amassed five 35 star
reviews within five three years rather
so um
yeah so and i never look for work
anymore i've gotten tons of compliments
and i get texts that say we love you and
tons of bonuses and cards and chocolates
and things and so it's made me very
happy
but some sadness has come into my life
within the last four plus years my dad
passed away
and so i guess part of my question is
that because i've reduced i don't have a
lot of space
it turned into
a big project
which is
pretty done now but there is still a lot
of stuff left of my dad's and i just
don't know what your opinion would be or
your thoughts on uh what do you do in a
case like that i mean i'm trying to keep
some things sentimental things i can't
keep everything i really am i had a wave
the other day in in thoughts of possibly
trying to move to just
i don't know just clear out more and
it's hard because you know it's just
sentimental so i don't know what you
would say about those things
well having gone through it first with
my dad five years ago
um
and with my mom now
and i bought their house so i live in my
childhood home and it's so much my mom
and dad and it's just so
feels so good
um
but i always know when i get quiet what
thing
to get rid of
that week or that day you'll just i i'm
i don't
they they might disagree with me but i
can't be in a hurry with it i have to
just go
one i think these guys said if you don't
yo we all know the how yeah get a
dumpster and get rid of it but if you
don't know the why
it comes back in
so you'll just clutter it up again with
other meaningless stuff
so i think when it comes to grief
because grief has no timetable
i think you're going to know it when you
know it when they were joking about cds
and vhs's and things like that i
literally have a rack
i kept about a quarter of my mom's vhs's
it looks really cute because it's the
one she loved the most and i said will
they be there forever probably not but
if they are are they hurting me no if
they do
then they have to go and i'll know the
why
so i think don't be hard on yourself
take your time
but recognize
when the shift is taking place so you
don't quote unquote wallow
so you'll you'll know you're i mean if
you take yoga this seriously which you
obviously do you know in your heart when
it's time to let go
you know and i i don't envy you going
through it but you got a sister in it
because i am too so
you know you'll do the right thing
thanks
it's spot on the the the how to is not
going to be helpful because
ryan could give you a how-to like his
packing party right and and say get rid
of all the stuff and then you end up
regretting that and then feeling
resentful well toward ryan or or uh
which is okay but um
uh you wouldn't be the first person
uh but you really would feel resentful
toward yourself right and so that's why
the how needs to be birthed out of the y
my mom 14 years ago found out she had
stage four lung cancer and
um
it's 2008
and and
she was down and uh she had just moved
down to st petersburg florida to finally
retire on social security she found this
the perfect place to be this little
one-bedroom apartment and so she crammed
64 years worth of stuff into a tiny
one-bedroom apartment
and shortly after she moved down there
she found out and then she spent the
next eight months or so going through
chemo and radiation and then eventually
she passed and i spent a lot of time
with mom that year in florida as she
sort of struggled through that whole
process and
when she passed i needed to make one
more visit down to florida it was to
deal with all of her stuff and
and that was sort of the impetus of all
of this because i'm going through all of
her things and i didn't have enough room
in my big-ass house for all her things
so it was rent a giant truck rent a
giant storage locker with climate
control because her stuff needs to be
comfortable
and uh
just lock it away in perpetuity it
wasn't really i wasn't getting value
from it what i was really doing was i
was creating a mausoleum of stuff and
maybe once you had to go visit it and
look at it or something theoretically
although if i'm being honest with myself
i was never going to i was just going to
pay a few hundred dollars a month
to waste that money to store things i
wasn't getting value from and worse
and this is what lisa alluded to here
the stuff wasn't the problem it was the
cost of the stuff not just the monetary
costs but the emotional the
psychological the mental clutter that
holding on to those things create all
that space it takes up in the back of
your mind and so
when you let go of the stuff it's not
really about letting go of the physical
possessions that's helpful it allows you
to move into a studio apartment
but
it also is about freeing up
the space in your heart
to make room for the things that are
truly important to you now that's not to
say that i didn't hold on to some of
mom's stuff i certainly did here's the
paradox of minimalism though whether
it's sentimental items like my mom's
stuff or just everyday useful items by
owning fewer things i get far more value
from those fewer things
than if i were to water them down with
10 000 or a hundred thousand
trinkets that simply get in the way
because what is clutter clutter is
simply
holding on to things
that no longer add value and get in the
way of the things that do
and if the things you're holding on to
or clutter because they're getting in
the way well then that is a sign that
you can begin
to let go and then once you do you'll
realize oh the things that remain
because we're not the deprivationists
we're not about getting rid of
everything we're not monks or aesthetics
and i think it's important to make that
distinction because having those few
things left
you actually amplify those you get far
more meaning and joy sentimental value
from those things
than if you were to have everything
weighing you down right yep yeah
thedeprivationists.com was taken so
you're almost a
thank god
oh this reminds me i went down um
my grandfather passed away a few years
ago and my grandma had to sell her house
and downsize and
she was like you should come down like
you'd be the perfect person to
help me help me downsize and
i am not the perfect person to help you
downsize because i'm i'm very
blunt
and uh my patience with it is like i
mean i was able to conjure that context
of compassion
um but it's not something i
love to do with with my grandma helping
to get rid of her stuff because it's a
process it's a huge process but i
remember as i was like helping her get
rid of everything she has this
collection of stein she's from germany
like she's um she moved over here when
she was like 19 years old
so she was like born and raised there
and
i was like admiring her collection
and she was she saw me looking at it she
was like you should take all those
steins
and i'm like
i'm like oma i love you i was like and
that's an amazing offer i was like i
will take one of them
and the reason why i
bring this up is because like josh said
we're not the deprivationists like i
i like having that sentimental stein i
mean i use it to put some like change
and you know
it's random stuff in there
um
but i look at that
and it reminds me of my oma and it makes
me think of all the awesome times we had
and like i totally understand that like
my memories are not in that stein but
but things can certainly trigger
memories
and
i would feel the same way if i actually
i would feel worse if i took taking that
whole collection well now i've got a
whole collection of signs and i got to
display them and i got to worry about if
i got space for them
where now
i have that one sentimental thing i look
at it it triggers memories all the time
it's a beautiful thing
but if i had all those signs it would it
would actually be doing it the opposite
it would be causing me a lot a lot of
stress so it's okay to hold on to you
know a sentimental thing or two but yeah
holding on to a horde of sentimental
items
there's not much sentiment in that
thank you
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free